[Music]
week thirty I think Adam doesn't even
matter I know why I've brought it up but
anyway I hope you bros had a great week
as always it's always a lot of fun to
make videos for you bros i also want to
mention if you keep keep submitting the
intros for free it's always a lot of fun
just leave them as a video response and
i'll find them eventually it's like an
ongoing thing that you can keep going
forever forever I don't mind if you want
to meet me this summer actually pretty
soon I will be speaking at Nanak Nanak
conference in Spain I'll just talk about
stuff I'll just pretend that I know what
I'm talking about
and that should be pretty fun then only
one day after I'm gonna be a Dreamhack
in Sweden so I'm first gonna go to Italy
and then Spain and then Sweden so it's
gonna be a lot of traveling ahead of me
so I probably won't have time to upload
videos and I know there's was there's a
lot of you bros who's worried that you
know he's moving to LA I'm moving to
Italy and it's only for the summer and
after the summer I will be back so don't
worry breath you can come don't know I'm
not leaving my roots I want to know how
their competition I know how I do a lot
of competitions but it's for you bros
after all and for us to kind of bond and
get that extra touch
I don't know between our noses
apparently
what the hell did I say sometimes I just
wonder well before I mentioned the new
one I want to remind you that there is
still the cry of fair competition it's
two months you have on you so if you're
in summer break and you don't know what
to do
and why not make some scary cry of fear
mods for me to play we have really
awesome prices my onyx gaming company
have sponsored us with awesome prizes so
definitely check that out I'll leave a
link in the description go do it but the
new your competition is basically a
Happy Wheels map competition I know I
read someone suggested in comments and I
thought it would be a great idea just
create a map and name it we're back and
whatever you want and so I can find it
and I will choose my favorite I'll be
judging from creativity humorous how
well-made it is and put effort a detail
unique I don't know if I said that but I
know there's gonna be a lot of
irresponsible dad mess probably but I'll
live it and look out for other things as
well I'm really looking forward to play
them the best one will win the best 3
will win it
goodbye t-shirt all alright that was
pretty much all I had to say as always
most importantly I want to thank you
Bros for all the support I know I said
every episode but I kind of feel like
our love here going I don't know I just
feel like I get more and more support
from every every week and it's really
amazing to see I still read all the
comments that I can and it's like I said
I always take suggestions and I listen
to you bros what you say I really feel
like this is a channel that we run
together
it's it's really amazing so far and I
can't wait what more sounds I feel
really cheesy when I say all this but
it's it's really a lot of fun this
channel I love doing everything that I
do for you both so as always I got a
punch you know that's gonna punch you I
used to joke the last time too I know
there was one guy though I saw you were
like what what is he doing is he gonna
punch you're gonna punch me no we don't
punch here we broke this alright
but anyway are you ready for us here we
go
[Music]